en 2027 il y aura une base spatiale
autour de la Lune et vous pouvez la
visiter Artémis et le plus grand projet
de l'histoire spatiale établir des bases
permanentes sur la Lune et sur Mars pour
que les astronautes puissent faire des
séjours de longue durée mais ça se fait
pas en un claquement de doigt il faut
d'abord construire le SLS un lanceur
spatial qui enverra des humains sur la
Lune en 2025 un beau bébé de 98 m de
haut pour 2600 tonnes qui a effectué son
premier lancement de test en 2022 mais
aussi la lunargetway une station
spatiale placée en orbite lunaire qui
servira de relais aux astronautes et
vous pouvez les visiter à la Cité des
Sciences et de l'Industrie qui lancent
le 17 octobre sa nouvelle exposition
permanente mission spatiale 1000 m² pour
vous immerger dans le futur de la
conquête spatiale il prévoit une
reproduction à l'échelle de l'ailab le
premier module d'habitation de la
lunargetway pour ça ils ont lancé un
financement participatif n'hésitez pas à
les aider le projet est vraiment
incroyable tout est en description car
oui vous avez bien entendu